oh here again one of the most
challenging things is when you get given
a question that requires some visual
that isn't directly handed to you now
this particular question does want to
hand it to you because the graph is
it's a difficult unusual looking graph
they say it's provided in a textbook but
let's actually do it in desmos in case
you're not sure how to do this i can
show you how
to work it through so let's put that to
one side
i don't need any of these values from
earlier new blank graph
let's move this over a little bit okay
so
it says here we've got a couple of
graphs that are sketched together
so i'm going to start by putting in the
first one x
minus functions i need to trink function
sine x when you have a look at it it's a
pretty
weird bizarre looking thing right like
what is going on here it's sort of like
a
weird looking slippery dip that goes
forever okay so there's x minus
sine x and then i also need let's bring
back this i also need x
which uh is familiar familiar familiar
lee
is that a word anyway um it's it's the
old familiar line
through the origin that has that
gradient of one okay it's sketched
together
it says find the total area enclosed
between these graphs
so we're getting an area between curves
again between
or from x to x equals 0
to x equals 2 pi now you might be less
familiar with this you can actually do
domain restrictions
in desmos some of you have had this
shown to you by your teachers
whoa i'm highlighting stuff why am i
doing that to get your domain
restrictions what you need
are those curly braces so it's the ones
that look
like this these are the curly braces
they tend to be if you think back to our
work on function notation a little while
back that's how we write our
domain restrictions so you can see them
in the
in the bottom of the keyboard near the
middle so i'm going to put these curly
braces in
and then you restrict the domain however
it is that you like
so i'm going to go from naught to
2 pi so what you can see is i've got
let's move this over a little bit
i've got just this little portion here
okay of the graph
i'm going to do the same thing for x
because both of the graphs are
restricted
and i'll restrict them in exactly the
same domain so from naught
to 2 pi okay
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
shuffle this out of the way we don't
need it
i can see my graph here beautifully
there's a few things i want to point out
for starters when you use desmos from
scratch the default setting
is that you are in radians and you can
see that if you have a look at the
numbers on the axes
sine x where does it usually have one
full loop
it's going to be the same as this x
minus sign next thing it has one full
loop
at x equals 2 pi that's why they've
chosen this particular boundary
now it doesn't look like x equals 2 pi
because we're not familiar very well
with the decimal expansions but
if pi is 3.14 then 2pi is about 6.28
right and you can see it there over
there on the right hand side you're like
oh yeah it just goes past 6.
now to make it even more obvious to you
and again some of you may be familiar
with this feature in desmos
if you change the way that the axes are
written
the scale is written then you can see it
much more obviously so go to that
spanner icon in the top right hand
corner
and then when you have a look under
x-axis and y-axis
you can see there's an option there on
the right-hand side that says step
so what this means is how much does it
step up by
each time as you go up and down the axis
if you have a look at the moment the
step is 2
there's 2 4 6 8 going up the y-axis and
it's the same thing
on the x-axis so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to change the step
into something that fits radians namely
pi so
again you can actually type pi on your
keyboard
or you can just use that pi symbol
that's over there in the bottom left of
the desmos keyboard if i hit pi there
have a look at what has happened to our
x-axis now there's zero
then pi on two then pi three pi on two
and of course
two pi where we end just for
completeness and might as well do it
for the y-axis as well so this looks
much better right i can see exactly
where i'm integrating
in fact i'm just going to grab this
screenshot because i want to draw all
over it
let's just grab the appropriate section
in here
and now i'm just going to come back into
my notes
and let's look at this picture together
so that we can
work out how to evaluate this area
okay so i've got the picture now i'm
ready to actually
come back to what they've asked which is
find the total area enclosed between
these two graphs so if i come in here
closer you can see
here is the area i'm interested in right
there's the first
of the regions and then there's another
one up here
okay now i'm going to just firstly state
what the area is equal to in terms of
appropriate
integrals so i've got two that you can
see um the left-hand side and the
right-hand side
so i'm going to call this guy a1 and
this guy
a 2. so what would be the integral for
a1
it's an integral rather it's an area
between two curves so i just need to
know which is the top and which one's
the bottom
now the top one in this case is the blue
line which is
y equals x that was the formula given to
us in the beginning
so i'm going to write that as the
integral
starting from have a look it goes from
naught and then where does it end
well it ends halfway which on this and
this is why desmos was so handy for us
that's pi right there in the middle you
can see that's where a1 finishes in
terms of its x values
so i go from not to pi i'm going to take
the
top section and then i'm going to
subtract this
bottom section which we said was x
minus sine x yeah there we go okay so
i'm going to do a subtraction here
x minus sine x bracket bracket
all with respect to x now before i go
any further i want you to notice
that i can actually use this knowledge
about a1 to work out
a2 as well in the trigonometric
functions
you're going to get lots of symmetry and
that's because you've got
odd and even functions sine is an odd
function
and cosine is an even function tan is
also
an odd function too so because you get
this symmetry all the way through i hope
you can see that a1 and a2
are identical in size so therefore
i can say that a2 i'm going to state
it's integral in a second but
i can say it's equal to a1 so i can just
double that and work it out
this is a 2 by the way if you're curious
i'm going from pi
to 2 pi and at this point the red graph
is on the top so it's going to be
x minus sine x and then i'm going to
subtract
the bottom function which in this case
is now x that would be a 2 and you can
go ahead and
you can integrate it but i'm always
interested in saving as much
time as i can so instead i'm going to
say from the graph
a1 equals a2 by symmetry
always keep an eye out for symmetry when
you're working with trigonometric
functions
so therefore i can say the area is just
double a1 and i don't need to even touch
a2 and i can dust this integral off and
be done with it
so i'm going to grab this integral from
up here
and as we've seen in many situations i
can do some simplification here before i
actually begin the integration that will
make things a lot easier for me
from naught to pi i'm going to have this
let's go to more visible color this x
and this x in here they cancel so i
don't need to write them
and then i've got this negative times
minus sine x so the negatives will
cancel just leaving me with
sine x dx so don't forget you are not
differentiating the primitive is not
cos x the primitive is minus cos x
from naught to pi i'm going to
just be really careful with my minus
signs here so
i'm going to take a minus sign out the
front
i'm going to still have the same
primitive here
from naught to pi and now minus sign
and i'm going to do top boundary take
away bottom one so this is
cos pi take away cos naught
now if you want to think again about the
what
cause looks like the graph it's this
valley looking shape that i mentioned
before so cos of pi is right spec bang
in the middle it's going to be
negative 1. you can see that y value
that i get over there so this is
minus negative 1 out the front and then
cos of 0 this guy in here is
up here so that's just a value of 1.
so well so many negatives negative of
negative
2 that gives me 2 but don't forget this
is an area
so therefore i conclude area is
2 square units
so hope you found that helpful remember
the graph is super important and the
accuracy of it matters so in other
situations where you're not provided the
graph
take the time to develop the skill so
that when you need to graph
in order to help you work out an
interval you can do it efficiently
quickly
and then focus on the other parts of the
question the calculus parts